you
it seems like you know when we talk
about genius there is a sort of the that
that creative capacity that we all have
to some degree but then there is the
question of degrees so and do do you
think neuroscience is giving us some
answers as to why some people have it
and some people don't
well I think neuroscience and genetics
as well so so recently there's been
studies looking at like musical talent
and it shows that there's actually a
really large genetic component involved
and so I think when we see these people
who are at the way you know top ends you
know like three standard deviations out
from the norm you're looking at a
combination between somebody who's born
with a particular predisposition to have
a talent plus the practice so for you
maybe you know you can practice from now
until tomorrow and you'll only get to be
so good as a concert pianist but if you
were doing that Plus you had a genetic
predisposition you might get to these
really far extremes and people might
call you genius but it's it's it's a
combination of the two I once went
around the world and met these people
called superhumans who were like
extraordinary in a particular domain
like what like for example a person with
an extraordinary memory or who could
withstand an enormous amount of pain and
there all sorts of these things that are
way outside the norm a man who could
hold his breath underwater for 22
minutes which is actually amazing yeah
and when you look at it and we did
experiments on them it's a combination
of having a different physiology like so
for instance the man who could hold his
breath underwater had a larger lung
capacity but then he practiced and
learned meditation learned how to slow
his body's metabolism and did all these
other things that led him to hit this
extreme it's the same thing with
cognitive capacity so even IQ right it's
it's it's a measure of different
cognitive aspects you know reasoning and
verbal abilities but with practice you
can get to be the best within your
biological constraints mm-hmm you know
you hear about genius being associated
with some of these disorders like
schizophrenia obsessive-compulsive
disorder these these things I mean do
you think that they're interrelated or
do you think at the very least we could
learn something about genius from
looking
people who are dealing with these
disorders so yeah I mean there's a lot
of controversy a controversy in this
area because it's not necessary to have
some sort of you know psychopathology in
order to be a genius and a lot of people
conflate these two ideas like the mad
genius and it happens that yeah there
are a lot of people who are very
talented who also happen to have a
mental disorder a lot of the mental
disorders are initially things that are
adaptive like even OCD you know it's
good to sort of have structure and have
certain rituals but when it gets to be
extreme then it becomes problematic so
these are things that we all have that
are adaptive that sometimes go a little
too far extreme it doesn't necessarily
mean that that correlates with
creativity however if you do think about
it something like OCD where you're
really a certain type of OCD where
you're really paying attention to the
detail might allow you to put in the
hours to you know for example like
Darwin to obsessively collect all of
these things but that in itself is not
enough he also I think needed the
divergent thinking the creative thinking
to put all the pieces together so
although there might be some sort of
advantages with some of these disorders
in the sense that it might make you be
more focused on a particular task I
think it's not enough there's still
something else there and so in a sense
these people might be Jesus despite
their disorders hmm interesting I me
because I would think that you know they
would when you talk about divergent
thinking and making these novel
associations as you say like you can
make an infinite number of random
associations and so that line there
between what's a brilliant insight of a
genius and what's something that's a
dream or a delusion might be kind of
hard to draw the line there well if you
think of someone like let's say John
Nash right hood they did this whole so
John Nash beautiful beautiful mind he
was a math profession mathematician at
Princeton yeah oh yeah and what was
interesting is that it so it appears
that when he wasn't taking his
medication and which allowed his
schizophrenic symptoms to sort of you
know
crank up he wasn't able to do his
creative math at that only right it
became too detrimental so there might be
there is a point in which you know too
much outside of the box thinking it
leads to non creative ideas just random
associations novel associations
delusions so when he had his mitigation
and it pulled back his symptoms that's
when he was able to be sort of you know
work that was sort of genius or anymore
but I think again it was in spite of his
disorder not because of it
that being said people who have certain
types of mental illness have different
wiring in their brain and part of that
having a different kind of wiring so to
speak could in some sense be related to
having a different way of thinking which
could produce these genius type thoughts
can you like you know if you pick out
one outlier like one I'm Stein is there
that much that you can learn just from
studying them I mean there's it possible
to unlock an individual's genius so I
mean people have looked at Einsteins
brain actually got to see it when it was
on display at the Wellcome Trust in
London which was really cool um doesn't
look it was active his brain actually
know it should look like a lid the
sulcus there oh yeah he had he had
variation in his like I think it was the
Sylvian fissure and there was a couple
of things that were different but you
far as I'm concerned I don't think you
can learn that much just by looking at
an individual brain we all have little
quirks and you know no two brains are
exactly the same so I think it really
has more to do with the way not just
Anatomy but it's its function and that
has to do with the way it's wired and
unless we could really see his brain in
action you know you're only gonna get a
small little piece of the puzzle if
you're just looking at you know
anatomical structure and for example if
we take two people who have exactly the
same sort of lesion or area of damage in
the brain and then we do cognitive tests
on them you know one person might have a
very severe deficit in a certain area of
thinking and another person might not
with the same exact lesion so there's a
lot of differences and you can't just
look at one brain and understand
whole picture
you